les haillons très bien parce que moi
j'arrive du congo 1 j'ai passé quelques
semaines au congo a travaillé sur ce
qu'on appelait dans le temps les pygmées
autrement dit la débâcle et on y est en
train de les expulser de la forêt alors
je n'ai pas à prendre partie pour eux je
constate simplement qu actuellement tout
est fait pour faire en sorte qu'au nom
de la biodiversité la conservation de
réservoirs de carbone liées à des
investissements et un désintérêt y
compris de ces peuples anciennement
chasseurs cueilleurs qu'on a cherché à
sédentariser de la forêt mais c'est vrai
dans une vraie question parce que toutes
les réserves en afrique wichita des
masaï avec ses cartes et finalement si
mon collègue et j'entends bien son
argument dit ça se fait sur les animaux
dans ce cas là c'est l'argument
d'autorité qui fait qu'il n'ya plus de
débat il ya plus de conflit il ya plus
de possibilités de conflits le conflit
doit disparaître ne serait ce que parce
que les animaux sont en cause or
effectivement on pourrait retourner la
perspective et c'est la situation à
laquelle je me suivent sur laquelle je
me suis retrouvé face à des individus
qui effectivement défendre l'idée de
pouvoir continuer et seront patrimoniale
iseo titre justement qui sont chasseurs
cueilleurs si ce n'est qu'ils ne peuvent
plus exercer ce niveau des terrains
[Musique]